a coral reef in costa rica's moreno by
llena national park these corals look
the way they're supposed to marine
biologist Rodrigo viotti is satisfied he
says they look really good that's
partially because there are strict rules
in the National Park snorkeling is
allowed but touching anything is
strictly forbidden for Mika ish learn
fuccked from the german society for
international cooperation the marina by
inna national park is exemplary here it
was possible to get local residents
involved in protecting nature concert at
your consultation is essential when it
comes to arriving at solutions for
mediating between conservation and usage
interests one example is retraining
fisherman fernando manga cadenas now
works as a tour guide nakamura operation
please there's more money in tourism so
we have better living conditions and can
offer our children a better future me
assure invoked wants to see whether this
model can be applied to other national
parks he works as a political advisor in
the costa rican capital San Jose his
partner here is Marco araya Bronte's
from the national system of conservation
areas so to a venomous lower ha we've
been working with the german society for
international cooperation for three
years yes the experience has been very
enriching and productive doer Costa Rica
now has 170 conservation areas some will
have to have their border redrawn due to
the effects of climate change young in
length of corner thanks to a gap
analysis we discovered that certain
conservation areas are too small they're
not big enough to be able to adapt to
the effects of climate change Lima
affected Nicky anger pasta xylophone and
there's not enough money this mangrove
swamp on the Pacific coast for instance
is suffering from the use of pesticides
on nearby plantations
but enforcing laws and compensating
local residents is expensive the
political analysts idea is to try to get
income from carbon dioxide offset
schemes since mangrove swamps absorb a
lot of co2 the hotels are also being
asked to do their part a large hotel
chain already supports school children
who are reforesting coastal areas it's a
model project that needs a lot of
imitators um we have a budget of maybe
50 to 60 million dollars a year provided
by the Conservation Area authority but
we really need around 100 million to
manage everything properly idiotic to
krystal medics the gay eat sets
political advisors need a lot of good
ideas if they want to close that
financing gap